[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes environ
1600 devant moi
savez-vous que dans l'année qui vient
400 d'entre vous sera touché dans sa
santé mentale
et et oui et moins de la moitié ira
chercher de l'aide
santé mentale de quoi parlons-nous je
vais vous prendre quelques petits
exemples
Séverine c'estverine une jeune femme qui
dernièrement a eu un accident de la
circulation
rien de bien de grave on apparence juste
de la tôle froissée
pourtant
aujourd'hui encore Séverine incapacité
de monter dans une voiture
sa vie son avenir en son perturbé
comment aider Séverine que lui dire que
faire
pierre
et agent dans un service technique
vendredi dernier
c'était le pot de départ d'un de ses
collègues
toute l'équipe était réunie
sauf pierre
ses collègues s'interrogent
mais Pierre habituellement aime bien ces
moments festifs
un autre constat depuis quelques temps
Pierre mon épouse café et bien en
retrait bien silencieux
un autre qui est passé devant chez lui
dernièrement a remarqué son jardin sa
passion et devenu une friche
pierre ne va pas bien
mais que peut-on faire comment l'aider
que lui dire
Jérémy
Jérémy et cadre dans un service
administratif il partage son bureau
depuis plusieurs années avec le même
collègue
dernièrement le chef de service rentre
dans le bureau
comment ça a Jérémy n'est pas encore là
j'attends son dossier depuis il y a
certains temps il est encore à la bourre
le chef parti le collègue s'autorise à
ouvrir le bureau
et là pointe dossier mais une bouteille
de whisky
le collègue comprend mieux les
changements d'attitude de Jérémie depuis
quelques temps
mais que va-t-il faire de ce constat
comment va-t-il pouvoir aller vers lui
l'aider
Marie
Marie est suivi par un service
d'insertion
sa conseillère
on se tape qu'à chaque fois qu'elle lui
pose une question
Marie tourne la tête sur le côté
marque un temps de pause avant de lui
répondre
intrigué
elle demande à Marie-Mai pourquoi ce
geste pourquoi cette attitude
alors Marie de lui expliquer
avant de vous répondre je dois demander
à la petite Marie à côté de moi
vous l'avez compris
la situation
de Séverine c'est celle de quelqu'un qui
est touché par un trouble anxieux comme
14% de la population
Pierre lui traverse certainement un
épisode dépressif comme 7% de la
population
contagie pas besoin d'être expert pour
comprendre que ces troubles sont liés à
une addiction comme près de 5% de la
population
Marie c'est peut-être un peu plus rare
de croiser quelqu'un qui traverse un
trouble psychotique mais c'est toutefois
quand même prête de pour cent de la
population
des pierres marient Jérémy Séverine j'en
ai croisé des milliers dans ma carrière
au service de l'inclusion des personnes
présentant des troubles psychiques
mais vous
vous en croisez aussi tous les jours
comme beaucoup vous êtes dans
l'ambivalence entre passer son chemin
fermer les yeux ou tendre la main
ce constat le fait que les questions de
santé mentale soit une problématique
majeure de santé publique ont amené les
Australiens ils vanter un programme qui
s'appelle premier secours en santé
mentale
il s'agit d'amener dans la population
des connaissances de base sur ce qu'on
se font ces problématiques
d'informer sur des gestes les premiers
gestes basiques qui peuvent aider
quelqu'un à se sortir de cette situation
ce à l'équivalent du premier secours
physique
cette formation a été diffusée dans 25
pays dans le monde et il y a trois ans
nous l'association pssm France premier
secours en santé mentale France avant
décider de l'importer en France et de
l'adapter
l'objectif formé 700
000 citoyens d'ici 2030
il ne s'agit pas de former des experts
des soignants mais simplement des
personnes capables de faire le premier
pas de tendre la main vers quelqu'un qui
est en difficulté
cette formation va apporter des repères
de base pour comprendre ce que sont les
problèmes de santé mentale
va aider à ce qu'on puisse identifier
quelqu'un qui est en difficulté repéré
ses problèmes
va aussi guider pour savoir comment
aller vers ces personnes
comment les écouter comment apporter
cette première aide
elle va aussi donner des indications
pour savoir comment intervenir si la
situation est une situation de crise
elle va informer sur les ressources qui
peuvent être mobilisés
elle va aussi et c'est important tordre
le coup à un certain nombre
d'y défausses qui stigmatise qui
alimente des peurs injustifiées et qui
font reculer l'accès aux soins
car il faut être convaincu que cet accès
rapide aux soins est essentiel pour les
personnes en difficulté
il faut savoir que la majorité des
personnes qui vont se faire aider vont
se rétablir et retrouver une existence
satisfaisante
il faut aussi faire savoir que l'aide
première c'est celle des proches des
amis
de ceux qui sont dans l'entourage
cette formation
elle est accessible à tous sans
pré-requis
elle dure 14 heures
elle est organisée en petits groupes et
elle est disponible sur l'ensemble du
territoire
alors vous
qui connaîtrez un ami un voisin un
collègue un proche en difficulté dans sa
santé mentale
soyez prêts à lui tendre la main devenez
secouriste en santé mentale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]